good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast the u.s president joe biden
has said he is convinced his russian
counterpart vladimir putin has already
decided to invade ukraine speaking at
the white house last night president
biden warned that the u.s has reason to
believe russian forces intend to attack
ukraine in the coming days targeting the
capital kiev it comes with the prime
minister boris johnson heading to the
munich security conference later today
where he will make a plea to world
leaders that unnecessary bloodshed can
still be avoided by pursuing a
diplomatic route out of the conflict our
u.s correspondent martha kelner reports
from the white house a warning to the
world
we have reason to believe the russian
forces are planning to and intend to
attack ukraine in the coming week
in the coming days
we believe that they will target
ukraine's capital ki
a city of 2.8 million innocent people
the u.s says their intelligence
indicates that russian president
vladimir putin is already on the path to
invasion
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that
president biden stressed the daughter
diplomacy is still open but seemingly
only just
a huge moment in this ongoing and
unpredictable crisis the biden
administration had been saying an attack
was highly likely they then said an
attack was imminent president biden now
saying he believes that president putin
has made his mind up to invade
russia now poses such a threat from the
sea and on the ground they could stage
an attack at any time it might also come
from the air
these satellite images showing a new
deployment of more than 20 helicopters
on russia's border with ukraine
today the u.s vice president kamala
harris will address a conference in
munich about world security the stakes
couldn't be higher martha kellner sky
news washington
to our security and defense editor
deborah haynes um and deborah on the
ground where you are you're in um kiev
what's going on and where do we stand
well it's you know a fairly damp morning
here in kiev um there's no
speak's fairly quiet it's still quite
early
but people here will be waking up to
this news from the u.s president
saying that he is convinced that russia
is going to attack and not only that but
that their capital is going to be a
target so it'll be interesting to see
the reactions and we'll be getting them
today from people here in the city but
we've been warned we've had warnings now
for months
that there is going to be a potential
for an escalation here in ukraine and
now over the course of the last two or
three days events have started to move
very rapidly and also mirroring what
western officials have been warning
would potentially be the chronology of
events first of all we had that spike in
shelling across the
the line of contact in the east of
ukraine which has been basically a
frozen conflict for eight years since
russia backed separatists steve's
territory there
then we've had the warnings from these
russia-backed separatists claiming
without evidence that they believe that
the ukrainian armed forces are going to
launch
an imminent assault on them saying to
their people that they need to evacuate
images of buses
evacuating civilians from that area and
then today the separatist leader in
another statement calling on um troops
in the area to mobilize reservists to
to to form up ready for this supposed
attack that they're saying uh the
ukrainian armed forces plan to conduct
but that really does fit in because
there is no evidence of that happening
the ukrainian military say they have no
intention and no plans to do such a
thing and it all really does um uh but
support this idea that the russia back
well russia is planning on some kind of
pretext some kind of provocation that it
will blame on the ukrainian armed forces
as an excuse to go in
and that is that the the cards
are in place for that sort of escalation
to happen and at the same time you have
us and other western officials pointing
to what is happening on the ground
around ukraine that unprecedented
buildup of troops one u.s official
saying they number around 190 000 at the
moment that's the biggest mobilization
since the end of the cold war and one of
the biggest mobilizations of militaries
in europe since the end of the second
world war and in terms of the actual
capability and the threat that's posed
by these troops the u.s official has
said about 50 percent of the ground
troops are now moving into an attack
position so that all feeds into
why you had president biden last night
issuing such a stark warning
perhaps hoping that by calling out the
intent that he believes president putin
has it might make the russian leader
blink
okay deborah thank you
well boris johnson has called for
western leaders to unite against
vladimir putin as he heads to the munich
security conference later to make a plea
for unnecessary bloodshed to be avoided
away from the crisis number 10 has said
that the prime minister has handed in
his illegal questionnaire about claims
that parties were held in downing street
during lockdown our chief political
correspondent john craig has the latest
from westminster
after number 10 confirmed last night
that boris johnson has now returned to
the metropolitan police his
questionnaire about those allegations of
partying in downing street today the
prime minister heads for munich and a
big international conference where he
will stress the importance of the
western allies remaining united over the
crisis in ukraine the pm will make a
speech at the munich security conference
on the importance of western unity says
number ten he'll meet world leaders to
discuss current tensions and the visit
comes according to number 10 as allies
warn that an invasion of ukraine could
take place at any moment that is a
reference to president biden's dramatic
claim that he's convinced that president
putin has already decided to invade in
his speech the prime minister will say
there is still a chance to avoid
unnecessary bloodshed but it will
require an overwhelming display of
western solidarity uh beyond anything we
have seen in recent history allies need
to speak with one voice to stress to
president putin the high price he will
pay for any further russian invasion of
ukraine and he'll add diplomacy can
still prevail well as for those partying
allegations at number 10 says that the
prime minister has indeed received
private legal advice throughout this
process uh they're saying we now request
the police simply carry out their
investigation will not be commenting on
the prime minister's responses or any
other aspect of this subject until the
met provide us with an update on their
investigation
the clear-up has started after storm
eunice left a path of damage and
destruction as it ripped through the uk
yesterday at least three people in the
country were killed as record-breaking
winds tore down trees and battered
buildings recovery efforts could be
hampered as yellow weather warnings
remain in place today with strong winds
predicted aisha zahed reports
predicted to be the worst storm in
decades eunice hit with devastating
winds reaching record speeds of up to
miles per hour
red weather warnings led to tragedy as
multiple lives were claimed
the first confirmed death in england was
here in haringey in north london a woman
in her thirties lost her life to storm
eunice after a tree fell on the car she
was traveling in
fatalities were also reported in
merseyside hampshire and ireland either
flying debris or falling trees were
responsible
while coastlines were battered eunice's
rage was felt across much of britain
struggling to withstand the weather
travel was brought to a halt train
services suspended roads treacherous and
planes struggling to land at heathrow
as the storm moved over england's
capital the severity of london's first
ever red weather warning became apparent
as winds ripped into the roof of the o2
the downstream effects from the course
of the past 24 hours of trains cancelled
across the country berries cancelled
transport disrupted heavy snow as well
across the north of the uk so impacts
will be felt for several days to come as
we tried to return back to normal with
travel in particular
a yellow weather warning for wind
remains in place for parts of the south
and south wales the worst may be over
but the trail of destruction is
extensive and will likely cause more
disruption over the weekend aisha tsar
head sky news
this guy's millenniovic is in southeast
london for us this morning and milan a
lot of damage done there at the o2 arena
yesterday
yes those winds were really felt here
first time a red wind warning was issued
for london and the southeast and if i
move away you can take a quick look
perhaps how that dome of the o2 was
battered and that tent
was really shattered to pieces now
the o2 will remain closed today so that
the extent of the damage can be properly
inspected a thousand people were
evacuated yesterday but luckily no one
was injured there sadly as we've heard
from aisha's report at least three
people were actually killed in the uk
one person also in the republic of
ireland by either falling debris or by
trees and now the gusts of wind reach
122 miles per hour just off the coast of
the isle of wight things are much calmer
today but still it's not over and the
warning still in place from 6am to 6pm
for south england as well as wales and
travel disruption does continue now the
national rail said that most trains
won't be leaving this morning most
operators will start either in the
afternoon or tomorrow and there's a
speed limit as well across the entire
rail network to allow train drivers to
be able to brake if there's any
obstruction in the tracks such as trees
so this travel disruption really
it to continue throughout the weekend
okay milena thank you
well some of this morning's other news
now and police in canada say they have
made more than 100 arrests and progress
in disbursing truckers raising
authorities hopes for an end to the
three-week protest against the country's
covert 19 restrictions one officer had a
minor injury but no protesters were hurt
that's according to the interim ottawa
police chief
last week the prime minister justin
trudeau enacted emergency war powers to
remove those protesters
the boss of mi5
excuse me
has warned that russia and china are
trying to infiltrate britain by
targeting mps universities and
businesses
speaking to the daily mail the director
general ken mccullum called for an
overhaul to the uk's espionage laws to
deal with increasing interference from
powerful neighbors
the nhs is to stop accepting money from
the gambling industry to treat people
suffering from addiction as a record
number of people seek support the health
service will fully fund its own gambling
services from the 1st of april instead
of taking cash from the charity gamble
aware which is funded almost entirely by
donations from the industry
a us coast guard vessel has offloaded
more than 30 tons of cocaine and
cannabis worth over a billion dollars it
was seized at sea during a months-long
deployment off the coast of south
america
the hall brought back to fort lauderdale
in florida is one of the biggest in
recent memory
charlie chaplin was one of the most
iconic and well-known comedy actors of
the early 20th century but a new
documentary the real charlie chaplin
unearths his dark and scandalous private
life from being named as a genius
entertainer to a dramatic fool from
grace he's our arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer
what was your first moment that you
really knew you were famous
i stopped new york
this is the voice of silent movie icon
charlie chaplin
recorded during a rare interview in 1966
and a chance to actually hear the man
who was arguably the first ever global
celebrity
i could do any mad crazy people like
because the films were silent they could
travel all over the world and people
from all backgrounds could kind of enjoy
his films
and so he achieved a kind of fame that
hadn't been possible before he before he
came on screen the public idolized
charlie chaplin's rise to fame was
nothing short of meteoric given how from
the age of four he was in and out of
this workhouse now a cinema museum after
his mother was committed to an asylum
from here to an audience of 300 million
and while there is no question of his
impact on popular culture when it comes
to chaplin's private life there is an
argument that by modern standards he
wouldn't really be seen or heard
can i ask you when you married him the
documentary touches on how three of
chaplin's four wives were teenagers lita
gray was 12 when she acted with him they
married in mexico when she was 16 and
pregnant in california he could have
been charged with rape during their
marriage she said he'd fly into rages he
bugged her room and even pulled a gun on
her he was an extraordinary complicated
character
and had an extraordinary canvas of her
life he was always acting
he didn't want people to know the real
charlie post me to it is a very current
conversation whether you can separate
the art from the artist canceling
charlie chaplin we cancel the stories of
those women and that is as equally
problematic actually what the journey is
bringing those women stories which are
still happen today
over and over again
into the light
in silent cinema language was no barrier
making his appeal universal but as the
debate over how we judge historical
figures intensifies to truly understand
charlie chaplin his legacy now feels far
from black and white i had grown up with
the icon
but the man i had no idea who the man
was katie spencer sky news
let's get some more now on our top story
and the u.s president joe biden has said
he's convinced his russian counterpart
vladimir putin has already decided to
invade ukraine as tension between russia
and the west continues to rise nato
allies have assured the world that an
invasion from president putin will lead
to major sanctions let's speak now to
nato's former director of policy
planning fabrice portuguese thank you so
much for talking to us this morning what
do you make of what joe biden said last
night
i think this is part of a general
approach that the u.s administration has
been following which i think is quite
smart which is to preempt uh
president putin's next move remember in
2014 we were all taken by surprise when
they moved in crimea and then in eastern
donbass and i think the u.s
administration is this time making a
point of preempting to basically take
away the
surprise the strategic surprise effect
that poutine always does and always
keeps for himself
so how is this going to play out do you
think because everyone thought
wednesday possibly he was going to
invade and then we had that day of unity
now we've had your biden coming out and
saying this week in the coming days
what's going to happen every time they
alert the world to what they think the
russians are doing the russians won't do
it
it's a kind of declaratory preemption uh
but on the other hand i think it doesn't
cost anything to be on the kosher side i
mean when you have more than 100
000 russian forces deployed by the
russian ukraine border and these are not
just soldiers these are heavy equipment
uh military hospital i mean all the
stuff you need to uh invade a country so
i think
the united states is being extra
cautious and at the same time as they
said i think they're taking away that
kind of
a surprise effect that putin has always
shown to to like to use both in ukraine
but also remember a few years ago in
syria
so the munich security conference
happening today interesting they don't
usually talk about their own backyard
but this
this conference
it's all about ukraine isn't it what do
you think will come out of that
well i i think it's going to be mostly
uh let's call it an internal
conversation between western nato
allies since for i think the first time
in many years
uh russia is not going to be represented
there
not that a foreign minister lavrov uh
was saying things that were very new
fresh uh constructive every time he was
speaking but at least symbolically there
was a russian presence uh so i think
he
has spoken there hasn't he
sorry
putin himself has spoken at the
conference yes in 2007 and that speech
was important because if you read it he
announced pretty much
what he was not
exactly doing but his intention that
actually have been expressed in 2008 in
georgia then in ukraine so actually we
put in and look at what he does because
he's often quite coherent even if that
clearance is a threat to us and to
ukraine
now you used to work for nato just how
do you think nato is looking on in all
of this we've had
one of our mps the head of the defense
select committee saying listen they
blinked they should have gone into the
ukraine far sooner they should be in
there with their armies now but then
we've also had lloyd austin in the last
couple of days the secretary for defense
um the u.s saying that
he thinks nato has never looked stronger
well i think
the first reflex of nato is always to
look inside uh at the basically at
protecting
assuring the defense of its own members
and i think this is where uh
the conversation is now and i understand
they're making plans to augment the uh
uh
forces presence on the nato eastern
flank uh which was the case already
since 2014 but it's going to be probably
strengthened because of what putin is
threatening to do in ukraine then i
think the next question is how do we
work
with others including european union who
has the kind of first responder
power when it comes to sanctions
because nato is part of a bigger whole
also what the us does individually
that has to somehow make sense in
stopping or warning putin that the cost
of action would be extremely high
okay fabrice thank you so much for
talking to us this morning
time for a quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well the weekend remains unsettled with
further wet and windy spells although
the winds won't be as strong as those
associated with friday's storm eunice it
will be a chilly start this morning for
much of britain with a scattering of
wintry showers and a risk of ice in the
north
thicker cloud outbreaks of rain and
brisk winds will affect parts of ireland
and southwest britain wet and
increasingly windy weather will push
across northern ireland england and
wales today with some snow mainly over
northern hills
a reminder of our top story this morning
the u.s president joe biden has said
that he is convinced his russian
counterpart vladimir putin has already
decided to invade ukraine the east of
the country is on the front line of the
crisis and has been a region split by
fighting between the ukrainian military
and russian separatists our chief
correspondent stuart ramsey is in
ukraine and reports now from the front
line near the town of pophasneh in the
donetsk oblast
even main roads are part of the
battlefield in this conflict
for two days this ukrainian position has
been hammered with rockets fired from
separatist lines further up the road
new debris litters the whole area
the mist adds to the sense of foreboding
this is a scary place
made worse by the sudden quiet after
hours of explosions and the soldiers
don't like it
[Music]
[ __ ]
bits of rocket lie next to holes in the
punctured tarmac a direct route to the
russian-backed separatists within sniper
range we can't go further than this uh
these sandbags and this defense position
that road goes right to the separatist
uh controlled area it's not very far
away what's really interesting though
these
uh tank
traps
they say were targeted
um which led them to believe
that um
there's a potential ground
invasion of this area being planned uh
it's never happened before they were
saying and it's it's interesting because
these lines have been here for years
they'd very rarely move and it was the
first indicator they've had that
actually maybe
the separatists and the russian forces
are thinking coming down this road and
of course you can hear
explosions around us all the time
we move forward through the mud and snow
of the front line trenches
some lined with wooden planks to stop
the trench walls collapsing
every day now feels much more like world
war one
across this 300 mile demarcation line
rockets and mortars are being fired by
both sides whatever their leaders say
they are both firing
at the nearest point to the separatist
positions the duty soldiers keep a
constant watch
at times they listen to the firing on
other positions trying to identify the
caliber of the incoming rounds
across this long battlefield the
soldiers all agree that things are
ramping up things are different now
everything is more intense
[Music]
well it's taken us a long time to get up
to this defensive position because the
fighting has been so intense it was
really intense when we arrived
and it's been intense they say for the
last couple of days and it's really
dangerous here these
these ribbons here
and on this side here
indicate that everything on this side
and on this side is mine
so there's really only this path and
this trench to get in
the soldiers are
really concerned
that there is actually going to be an
attack on them by soldiers rather than
what we've seen which is just the
criss-crossing of missile exchange of
fire but an actual attack on their
positions
so in their bunkers they wait for their
turn to once again take up guard duty in
the trenches
but this is where they retreat when the
rockets are falling
in recent days they've spent a lot of
time here
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine
well let's get some more now on the
current situation in ukraine the kremlin
has just confirmed that president putin
and emmanuel macron will speak by phone
on sunday that's according to the
russian news agency task it comes as
ukraine's president vladimir zielinski
confirmed he will attend the munich
conference later today sarah scuzio is a
research fellow at the henry jackson
society terrace thanks so much for
talking to us so a lot to get through um
let's talk about what joe biden had to
say last night what do you make of those
claims from the u.s president that he
thinks vladimir putin has already
decided to invade ukraine and will
target kiev
well i think we're all pinching
ourselves
the the whole idea in the 21st century
that another country could invade a
sovereign country ukraine's a founding
member of the un since 1945
is a bit surreal so um until this week i
was of the opinion that a full-scale
invasion um was not on the cards i
didn't think russia would go that far
and didn't have enough forces in play
and ukraine was simply too big to digest
but there seems to have been
certainly some
changes the change in atmosphere and you
see that with the false flag operations
taking place in in the occupied part of
eastern ukraine
as well as the call for the full
mobilization of those russian proxy
forces they're not really separatists
they're proxy forces
um and thirdly the the evacuations
of you of civilians living that area so
there's obviously something going on
um putin can't do nothing after bringing
so many troops practically 200 000
troops to the ukrainian border so
certainly something is on the cards
let's talk about today we've got putin
overseeing russian drills that were
brought forward from the fall
and then we've got this munich
conference going on zilinski saying he's
going to be there the uk's boris
johnson's going to be there
a why do you think those nuclear drills
were brought forward even though putin
says that they're not a danger to anyone
any other country and b what do you
think what
tangible
if anything will come out of the music
conference
well
i mean nothing much tangible will come
out of the munich security conference
russia's boycotting it
so the the what will come out will be
western resolve western a show of
western unity particularly nato and eu
and also
western support for ukraine that will be
on show
um but russia is using the
um the military exercises which are
taking place in belarus to show off
showcase its nuclear weapons because
it's a warning to the west it's a
warning to the west to that something's
on the cards like a military invasion
and that nato the us britain should
should pull back should not interfere
because remember we are a nuclear power
putin is a is a bully remember bullies
from school they love to sort of flex
their muscles i mean putin loves to hang
out without a shirt on and have this
macho image and nuclear weapons are the
ultimate you know viagra for these macho
men so it's basically
um a warning shot to brussels and to
washington stay back
this is our show we're gonna we're gonna
invade
and boris johnson when he goes to munich
today he is going to say there's still a
chance to avoid unnecessary bloodshed
and that diplomacy can still prevail do
you think that that's correct
i've never been um ever since this whole
artificial crisis began in november of
last year i've never been confident that
diplomacy will prevail of course
diplomats and politicians have to say
that and they have to try their best i
mean
sometimes they can pull rabbits out of
hats i mean not always um but i'm i'm
not optimistic i think this is all for
show the key key date is tomorrow the
20th why because the the russian bill of
russian exercises end tomorrow and also
more importantly the olympics end in in
china
and russia has always not wanted to do
something against ukraine um whilst the
olympics are still going on uh in 2008
russia made the mistake of invading
georgia during the chinese olympics and
china was not very happy about it so
let's watch tomorrow and monday in
particular because they could be crucial
um times but i don't foresee
any
any any intervention by france which is
more pro-russian than britain britain
certainly won't have any impact no
okay taras thanks a lot for talking to
us thank you
again you're watching sky news breakfast
with us this morning to look through the
papers journalist and author janelle
aldrid and writer and academic mo love
it there they are thanks a lot guys for
coming back to talk to us chanel why
don't you kick off with the guardian
page too um interesting the bma is
saying that the ending all covered
restrictions is premature
yeah they're saying it's premature
they're saying that it's actually not a
data-led decision and that once we
um
leave the regulations behind once
there's no self-isolating then the
numbers of covid will
once again rise and kind of go through
the population and i and i agree with
them in the sense that this is not a
data decision but i think it is a
calculated decision by the government
because of the fact that we've been
under regulations for two years and i
think it's in part financial decision i
think if you remember right to the back
right to the start of the regulations it
was all about protecting the nhs so they
didn't get overwhelmed that messaging
kind of turned into something else to
ensure that people did comply with
lockdown and i think that it's that
mixture of really really strong
messaging plus time going by that i
think has led to confusion as
regulations end as to why they were in
place in the first place you know we
can't stay in lockdown forever and i
think what we have seen is that the
halfway restrictions don't actually work
so when it's confusing people tend to
not comply so i think the government are
going with ending restrictions and we
can say whether or not we think it's
boris trying to please his backbenchers
but i think the fact that remains
regulations are very expensive and the
taxpayer has to pay and at some point
there's no good time to end it but it
does have to end at some point
it is interesting if you're looking at
hong kong and what's happening there
because they have they've had this zero
covert policy and now with omicron
because they've got so many cases
everything is just overwhelmed they just
can't keep up mo what do you think do
you agree with the bma that it's all a
bit premature to end all restrictions
no i don't really because i mean you
know they talk about it not being data
driven but what they're talking about is
a single set of data and that's the data
on corvid and actual fact there's all
sorts of data emerging about some of the
collateral damage of lockdown and we
know very um we've talked a lot about
cancer uh diagnosis we've talked about
heart attacks at home increased suicide
there's been an all
awful lot of collateral damage because
of lockdown and i don't think you can
only live our life through the prism of
corvid nasty disease though it is um and
you know the data we do have on omicron
is that it's much more mild disease and
i'm very much a fan of if you're not
feeling very well stay home and i've
never understood people who come into
the office when they've got streaming
called or they've got the flu and passed
it on have 24 hours 48 hours in bed when
you're feeling poorly and trying not to
spread disease i mean i think that has
worked for us as a society and as the
threat from omicron um
it makes the you know the pandemic less
of a kind of ongoing threat on our daily
lives because it's not just financial i
mean financial means people's jobs it
means self-employed people not being
able to kind of take opportunities it
means disruption to people's social
lives to their family lives and all the
rest of it so i i do think um you know
you you sort of notice that the public
instinctively know when the risk is is
high and start wearing masks and social
distance and then staying home and when
actually they're prepared to take that
risk and we do have the summer coming up
you know this is a this is a good time
for us to kind of get out and about and
try and restore some of the social
fabric of our society i think
let's stick on stay with this theme
because um guardian page 28 the story of
the canadian truckers mo um talk us
through that because they have been
there for three weeks now haven't they
protesting against
it's basically the uh vaccine mandate of
the canadian government
yes it's covered restrictions and
vaccine mandate and that's compulsory
vaccinations for truckers um
particularly crossing the border between
canada and uh and america um now
this story worries me a lot actually
because um what they are doing is they
are indulging in the lawful right to
protest
and what we've seen from the canadian
government is an incredibly
authoritarian i would say crackdown um
in terms of threatening to freeze bank
accounts taking away people's um vehicle
insurance so that they can no longer
work um and we've heard of police well
the guardians reporting police smashing
windows and and dragging truckers
through that um
i mean even president nixon who's not
necessarily the most illustrious
president in us history actually went
and spoke to uh protesters when that
when there was when there was a kind of
conflict between government and
protesters um so
you know whether you agree with the
protest or not and you know there have
been a lot of protests over the last two
years i do think you know lockdown in
the pandemic has
has meant that people have taken to the
streets and certainly kind of raised
concerns whether you're agreeing up with
the protesters really beside the point
um the fact that you do have a law for
rights protest that seems to be
forgotten in some of the coverage of all
this now i'm not saying that i don't
feel sympathy for the residents of
ottawa you know i think um some
injunctions have been taken out on the
the honking of horns i have to admit
that would drive me mad but there is so
many protests that drive me mad um but
this seems to be a particularly strong
reaction to in a liberal country the
right to protest chanel what do you
think because this issue of people's
right to protest has come up again and
again and again throughout this pandemic
hasn't it and justin trudeau as you were
just saying that actually invoked
emergency powers to get these truckers
off the road
no i i agree with everything that mo has
said really i don't think you build
trust that you're not an authoritarian
state by then clamping down further on
people i think we're seeing increasingly
our rights diminished in terms of the
right to protest and i think it is
actually very very very worrying and it
comes kind of back to what we were
talking about in the last about you know
nato and the west being the world's
policeman i think if this was happening
somewhere else they would be absolutely
intervening saying that citizens have
the right to protest peacefully and to
state their claim and i think actually
when we are really clamping down on
rights and in the way that they have and
to come down further in terms of bank
accounts and the police and all of the
things that are going on i think every
citizen should be worried about the
future of their free rights and the
right to demonstrate against things that
we believe to be unfair in the end you
know taxpayers we pay for our countries
to be run and therefore we should have a
say in how they're run and the
opportunity to oppose things that we
don't think are correct exactly but also
still get vaccinated because vaccines
work um janelle and moe thank you so
much